[Music]
you know what this music means the new
ps plus games have been revealed for the
month of october 2021. as always the
following games will be available for
free to playstation plus subscribers
from the first tuesday of the month
which this time is october the 5th first
up on the ps5 it's hell let loose a new
take on immersive online multiplayer
gunfights set during world war ii this
strategic shooter includes 10 hyper
realistic maps with more coming soon
from the normandy landings to the battle
for hill 400 hell let loose prides
itself in combining the arcade
simplicity and ease of call of duty with
the simulation of a game like arma 3 a
gritty recreation of war which is
arguably the most intense fps on console
the multiplayer game is centered around
a huge battle involving 100 players
simultaneously 50 vs 50. the weapons are
a perfect recreation of those found in
world war ii which means every weapon is
deadly one shot one elimination the
majority of the time if i had to
describe playing hell let loose i'd say
it's like playing in a war movie but
you're not the main character and you
will die a few times along the way to
truly get the best out of this you'll
need a squad with comms as tactics are
vital to achieving your world war ii
goals hell let loose releases on
playstation on the very same day it
releases on ps plus next onto the ps4
and first up is a golf sim yep sure is
pga tour 2k21 like usual with sports
games you've either already skipped this
part of the video or you're hoping
there's something mind-blowing about
this game there isn't but pga tor 2k21
is arguably the most accessible golf sim
there has been presented like a live tv
broadcast the career mode has you taking
on 12 real-life pros in a race to lift
the most silverware across the season as
you earn xp and sink putts you'll be
rewarded with more vanity items like
sweatshirts and hats the same element in
pga tour is in both the decisions you
make on the course and your execution of
shots swinging too quickly or slowly
will result in slicing or hooking the
ball into a greenhouse window if you do
choose to play this i definitely
recommend looking at the settings to
change those sim elements to find the
right difficulty for you released just
over one year ago pga tour 2k21 reviews
average out at 7.5 out of 10 which is
damn good and finally a game for
halloween mortal kombat 10 or is it x
first released in 2015 mkx brought us
eight brand new characters like cassie
cage the daughter of og's sonia blade
and johnny cage and she likes violence
just as much as her parents i gotta take
it easy on the shots i choose in this
video but rest assured mortal kombat is
even more deadly than you remember
fatalities are now taken to the next
level with every detail of gruesome gore
taken into account there's x-ray moves
that depict shattering bones and
devastating combos that make up the
majority of the battles and this was the
game which added variations which lets
you adapt your playstyle breathing extra
life and replayability into the game as
a breather away from the core mode there
is a story mode which is about five
hours long centered around the cage
family and the love of a dad for his
daughter it's weird to say the least but
for 2015 it's very good mkx reviewed as
highly as 9 out of 10 and as low as 6.5
so as always review scores mean
absolutely nothing you gotta play it to
know for yourself so get over here and
tell me what you think of this month's
games i'm adam you're awesome i'll see
you next time
[Music]